[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun
super excited to be talking about using
software to make people happier
we have Natalia man don't so joining us
on the show hello oh thank you very much
thanks for coming on really appreciate
it very excited very grateful to Alex
Kate Chen for introducing us that's such
an interesting person that he's
introduced this to so many cool people
we love him very much we love you Alex
also for those who don't know Natalya's
background she is a Brazilian developer
computer scientist freshman here in the
United States also she's been building
smart mood which we're gonna be talking
about it's a mood tracking app and a
happiness research project very excited
to be talking about that when we talk
about a lot of things about your journey
computer science a lot of things about
philosophy super excited all right let's
start with this big history perspective
on civilization we find ourselves as
stewards of earth what's your current
take on the human experiment so I think
I am marked missing - most people are
about society and civilization in
general people tend to be optimistic
about their own lives but pessimistic
about the world in general choose
interesting but I think that like
artificial intelligence there's like the
big thing going on right now and it's
definitely like if there is something we
should be worried about that it that is
it you you have you point out this
interesting thing that we tend to be
more optimistic about our lives but
pessimistic about civilization yeah I
think you guys from Steven Pinker from
his recent book alignment now that is
interesting
and there are feel psychological
theories about why that is but
BioCenter people to have sing and then
on the AI side of things it's like we're
kind of passing the torch to
non-biological intelligence yeah
and it's both the way that you talk
about it do you do you what is your kind
of take on this passing of the torch we
must like what are these principles that
we must pass it with in order for it to
be a smooth transition that is a very
complicated question because right now
we kind of are like teaching our friends
to a in a certain way like current
software is like trucking our alliance
and the things I share and all of those
things like are being used to optimize
for a new accountant but yeah it's
questionable whether that is like
exactly what we want to maximize in the
world in the future so like the question
about like what are the factors that we
do want to pass to AI is a big one is a
very big one and I'm just starting out
to figure it out we all are we're all
little like first graders trying to
figure out how to pass the torch a what
values and ethics to embed into the
passing of the torch just off off of
your you know of your just the time that
you've spent thinking about it what
would be potentially some of those good
values or principles to pass along
Oh happiness I guess like I am a
classically teri and in the end a
classical utilitarian yeah so I value
well-being and happiness and I hope that
hey I increases that in the world just
write it down to crazes yeah the
bringing utility or value to oneself and
one's family wants community when state
one's world is kind of one of the most
important things that one can do being a
creator rather than a consumer of a
constant state of being let's say
alright let's talk about this journey
this is interesting so come you hail
from Brazil from the capital of Brazil
and the how does one find themselves in
another part of the world growing up and
then how did you pick up your interests
how did you decide that you wanted to
make the move to the United States tell
us about this journey
it's a very long story since I was 8
years old
I kind of knew that I would want to move
to England to the United States and I
think the culture here especially here
in the Bay Area fits me a lot better
than the culture in Brazil I feel like
my personality is something that is more
accepted here than it was in Brazil like
this thing of being a little bit weird
and being creative and we love weirdness
it's so important in like a conforming
world to like be weird be yourself be
Center yeah that's something like about
here in the u.s. in Brazil they don't
have that as much in your culture they
don't value we're nurses marginal value
innovation as much just value so it's a
more collectivistic culture not as much
as some Eastern Asian countries but it
is pretty collectivistic and then UK so
you knew when you were around eight that
you want to make a move how did you how
did you find how did you find out though
that like that that the United States
culture was more accepting to like
weirdness and innovation
I read a lot of books like throughout my
life and read a lot online I came into
contact with like operationalize
community and transhumanist and UT and
effective altruism communities when I
was around 16 15 16 years old and I
delved deeper I don't feel like very
deep into it and they write a lot and
you notice that most of the interesting
people are around here and how did you
pick up your interest in computer
science yes so when I was younger I I
thought that I would be better
programming and I thought that it would
be it was kind of like bad at math so I
wasn't like originally interested in it
in the beginning but then later I
realized that last year I realized that
there were things that I wanted to do
the like I needed programming to do and
I realized that's like having a says
degree would be helpful to me in my life
and that was the beginning and when I
decided to study see us I thought it I
still thought that it would be something
that I would struggle with but then
later on last year like as I delved
deeper into programming I just figure
out that it's something that fits me
much better than I thought before I
think that it fits my personality very
well
and then no now when you start sort of
you know figuring out that you want to
make the move and there you want to
pursue CS you know how does that get
translated into like action into
actually happening for other people that
may be interested in making the move and
it was it was pretty crazy it was pretty
complicated but my parents no have like
a lot of money so I couldn't get
straightaway into a four-year university
so I applied to open animation coming to
colleges here in the area and i felt
quite bad about it but i realize like I
do value being here and I can do black
and I do plan to study as hard as I can
to progress so for university but and
like doing that is is indeed like a very
good beginning for people who who who
are foreigners and haven't spent several
years my blind show for university
steamers here in the United States and
preparing for that specifically which I
didn't because I thought I would say in
Brazil when I was like in the end of
high school
I'm so glad that you made it out here to
a culture that you feel like more
fitting and that's very important now
teach us about what you were going
through in your in your teens that got
you excited about doing happiness
research and this mood tracking and
working in mental health and having
people know that they can live their
life in a much more they can achieve
their goals that they set etc oh yes so
when I was in high school I had a pretty
severe depressive episode and that was
like my third depressive episode and I
started reading mental health research
secretary research and it made me feel
pretty bleak because like the prognosis
for people who have major depressive
episodes isn't that cute like people
just keep having them and I other
research more I realized that mental
health was if it was a thing that
impacted happiness a lot for people in
general and it effects a large share of
the population I think at least 20% of
the United States has like depression
and/or anxiety and that effects are
their happiness alot basically
throughout their entire lives if they
don't get treated well and ten million
have PTSD yeah that's you
and but then I got treated and it was
something that
it seemed like like the arm I got
treated I started taking wellbutrin for
my depression and improved my happiness
a lot and did agree to it you improved
my happiness like you made me feel like
it was something that people should
think about more it was something that's
like shouldn't be the last resort as it
was for me because there are a lot of
people I think that with like subsea
normal depressive episodes so they are
like we're just a little bit unhappy who
would benefit from from improving their
lives in that way by taking the right
psychiatric medications but they don't
do that and even people with severe
depression many of them go untreated and
it's something that can be improved on
like if people just get treated with the
current technology they can have much
better lives but it's often not
something that people think of
the momentum what's going on with mental
health is a direct result of the seed
the seed of the mind when it's born into
the world if it's given the right
compassion and love and nutrients for
the full creative flourishing of the
mind in the social fabric then there's
less of the depression and anxiety and
trauma that we see but then the ways
that in the current realm the world that
we live in we are figuring out these
ways to help people with their feelings
of depression anxiety or PTSD and you're
right that in some ways the psychiatric
medicines can assist also technology can
assist and this is where you decided to
pursue building technology for this
yes so I started developing smart mode
in order to have a better way to attract
my own happiness in order to figure out
what are the things that make me happy
out of like all the several factors that
could impact my happiness I wanted to
figure out which were the ones that
impacted me the most and this is
something that I think is important
because it's not Bute into our
psychology that life can be better than
it is the life will be much better than
it is mostly because we evolved in small
hunter-gatherer tribes where like there
wasn't a lot of possibility for change
like people couldn't simply move move
out to a better group that feed them
better people couldn't take the Hetrick
medications to feel better and there was
much less exploration as possible so
nowadays there is a lot of exploration
that we can do there is a lot of things
that we can change in our lives to
impact our happiness but that doesn't
come to mind very easily so
[Music]
that's partially why I started
developing hardwood it's so interesting
you take the big history perspective
again that evolving in hunter-gatherer
tribes made it so much more the degrees
of exploration were more limited you
couldn't just pick up and go to a
different area of the world on a plane
and and enjoy the culture in that area
that was maybe more open and weird and
more able to maybe leverage the tools
that had to be build businesses and
stuff like that so it's good to bring
that up
okay so so what specifically like for
you know for the case of yourself and
for the case of other people how when
someone experiences some sort of a
depression or some sort of an anxiety
how can something like smart mood help
track that mood through what variables
is it biometrics what is the analysis
yes so there were a beauty is that most
of the variables that people track
through the app through smart mood are
self reports so you receive a
notification in your phone two random
times during the day it should be
completely random and you answer like
how are you feeling and how productive
you've been and so what do you have
exercise or knowledge and there are
other things that I can track most of it
is made out of soft reports but if
people have Fitbit or Apple watch or /
ring that can be incorporated as
following - data into the analysis and
people can also choose to track pretty
much whatever they want with with the
app so like I myself can I can track
like whether I've meditated in a day or
not and see how that impacts my mood and
I can track that without other people
being asked what are they meditators why
were not so like each individual can
track whatever they want as well and
it's quite simple for me to get a
notification that calls me into smart
mood and then I just answer a couple
like you have look it's like a scale of
maybe one to ten on how you're feeling
yeah happiness how you feeling
productivity yeah and I answer these
couple questions and then you logged
that as a data point and I do this maybe
twice or three times a day yeah duh the
amount of times a notification shows up
a day should be random as well so this
is something that I'm still trying to
decide but it's probably going to be
from zero to four notifications a day
there should be unpredictable yeah okay
and then now what are then the insights
that I get provided from you as I
respond to you and I we gather more data
points like this looks like I've
answered maybe a hundred times let's say
you know over a period of a couple of
months and then what kind of insights
can we get and we have that other that
other image as well I believe that has
additional yeah yes so Deb makes a lot
of charts automatically so it mostly the
scatter plots the plots attract to
variables
new to the track mood and most of the
other variables are in the survey but
I'm going to I'm probably going to
expand that as well and you can also see
a histogram so you can select the basic
distribution of your ratings of your
mood ratings and you can appear you are
the more
you are things like that yeah and
they're probably very between different
people but for me there was pretty
strong correlation yeah and you can also
see a time series chart of your moods
show time which is I think the most
basic uncharted areas are suggest your
line your mood so Tonya would do time
yeah that would be interesting actually
to be able to right now the best kind of
tool we have is our Google Calendar to
really be able to go back like a week or
two weeks and like be able to see who
like what did I have that day what do
they do that day right and then like who
did I text or email or Facebook message
or whatever that day but to be able to
actually think back and like how did I
feel that day that's a very hard thing
to recall yeah and in order to make the
tracking easier that's largely why I
built yet and especially because a lot
of a lot of people around on the
Internet specifically like um saying
that there a lot of like life and
modifications that can make life better
like people telling you to eat in a
certain way or to meditate in a certain
way and saying that that made them feel
much better or like to try a supplement
or to take few supplements but usually
that is based on their memory and
and that can be problematic for like
obvious reasons like there is a certain
lack of objective data about what are
the things that actually helped those
people or not
that's those types of little activities
that can bring someone greater
productivity in the day greater
happiness during the day is crucial this
tiny little a maybe maybe you shouldn't
like for example before the show you
didn't eat anything
I feel good not eating something you
know sometimes when you eat something
before the show it can bring you bring
more of your your metabolic processes
into play rather than maybe this the
cognitive process of engaging with
someone else so or like when you wake up
and you do a little five-minute inward
reflection before you just you know grab
your phone so it's these tiny things
that can potentially do to kind of like
bring up your daily happiness or
productivity
yeah I think that is very important
because if you think about it we should
strive to do our best every day and to
work at our our maximal productivity
every day and fewer best every day and
not let small things affect how I feel
and I've been trying to do that and I
try to I try really hard to like figure
out exactly what makes me function and
feel the best and strive to like stay at
the best and not deviate from that
I love that goal it's there that's such
an important goal Matt look maximal
happiness and productivity on a
day-to-day basis be my best on a
day-to-day basis that is one of if not
like the most important goal be your
best every single day yeah and our minds
are largely there pretty much all that
we have as some hairs especially he
likes to say that has waken up vodkas
and he talks a lot about meditation and
he says that our mindset are all that we
have so I think that thinking a lot
about how to make our minds function the
best is a very important question yeah
all we got is this is this daily process
of you know waking up doing what we find
most meaningful in our lives and if we
can do our best to take the the kind of
like the may the more negative
experiences that don't drive us
happiness and productivity and slowly
get them out and focus on it that's
that's so important it's so important so
okay now is it is it already available
on iOS or soon
well Deb star so on that sorcery yeah I
have my winter winter quarter finals now
so probably work on that after the
finals do you like fine-tune it for Deb
sir but people can download it right now
they can download it yeah
from this one wood website from um yeah
um they should message me or answer the
emails in the side and they get at it
should be the testing group debate s
cool cool okay so for now enter your
email on the site on smart mood do and
then you'll get the email for the beta
testing and then eventually when it is
on the App Store will put that for a
link in the bump in the bio as well okay
and then eventually also on Android as
well down line
yeah just even like you're making it
easy for Pease or for people to be able
to reflect on yeah yeah on there you
know it's a good way to buy it to you
yeah which is so so important um now
okay you your you know your your
exploring building this right now you're
playing you know you're doing your
programming and Swift right now you're
playing around with computer science
you're playing around with your classes
and with your ideas you know as you kind
of build out smart mood what else are
you thinking are you thinking like
really focused on the maximizing
happiness and and productivity space is
that kind of like your where you want to
put your CS skills to to play
yeah pretty much not only I have a lot
of ideas I have way too many ideas I
have to like write them down and forget
about them but yeah right now that's
what I'm focused on
later on I'm really interested in
working on AI sift you as well and I
have way too many ideas that I want to
work on what is an an AI idea that
you're interested in working with um I
don't know a lot about machine learning
right now so that is something that's
like I will have to delve deep into too
much about it yeah it's it's a very
important feel to know more about it's
very very important both to apply it in
order to like explore my smart mode data
as well as in order to figure out how to
make it safe make sure that it's safe in
the long term I'm interesting that as
well yeah yeah that's a lot on the AI
ethics side of things which is very
exciting and glad that you're interested
in being a part of it
also what's really cool is on on your
website I found so many interesting like
eccentric phrases that I like I like so
much like an epistemic forager I think
that's so interesting the idea that
there's a bunch of kind of like chaos
and a noise that's happening and you
have to you know forage for the signal
for the truth in the world yeah that's a
phrase that I found in a paper from Kyle
Frizzle or anti Clark which was from a
paper about predictive processing of a
computational theory about about
psychology about human mind and I like
to phrase a lot I think it applies to me
very well because India and I'm a very
curious person I think what drives me
most is seeking knowledge
so if Sami foraging is it's a very good
way to describe what I do yeah the the
seeking of the knowledge and then also
making it applicable to other people
that are being born into the world and
having them more easily realize it and
apply it and I'm and of course like the
classical like effective altruism ei we
actually haven't done like a show
specifically on that although people
have been on the show and have talked
about the importance of that why do you
find that to be so important I really
like to generate to you which is to like
use evidence to figure out what are the
best ways to do good because
unfortunately there's a lot of charity
that is an effective and there's a lot
of social programs that they signify -
but they aren't life turns out that's
like pure gauge well isn't enough to
actually bring change in the world so I
really like it that there is this group
of people concerned with applying like
rationality to figure out where that
what are the best ways to good and yeah
I'm very interested in it and I want to
contribute as much as I can throughout
my life likewise and this is
we putting a a better more transparent
lens on the way that we give and
actually calculating the variables of
giving and what it does to another
person and their community how how to
best measure how to most effectively
help other people flourish this
extremely important and I think one of
the things that we've had the pleasure
of sitting down with I'm different
people from around the world that have
been teaching us that you know the big
thing is poverty so if you can just
eradicate poverty for someone if you can
give and it's not just like about giving
because they need something that gives
them meaning they need something that
gives them economic freedom themselves
so like having a like it to be easier
for them to pursue an entrepreneurship
or for them to pursue working at a local
business that doesn't have all of the
regulations and corruptions and and
glutton ease and Greed's that inhibit
businesses from starting up is a major
way for people to to be able to
effectively flourish themselves how
about you know we talked about
utilitarianism earlier we didn't really
talk too much about like atheism and
hedonism what are your thoughts about
about those
um those are pretty separate things I I
was raised in a Catholic family and in
back in Brazil and I was pretty much I
eventually became an atheist and I was
pretty much like the only atheist that I
knew at a time I think which made it
like a very important aspect of my
personality to me at a time right now I
know a lot of people with similar views
but it was pretty like interesting to me
too like oh this was something that was
a part of me and I didn't know anyone
else it was similar I think not even
like public intellectuals much first
only later I started reading Richard
Dawkins but yeah I became an atheist
when I was eight
yeah around a bunch of Catholics yeah
everyone in you is Catholic
pretty much yeah that's the type of hard
stuff to get yourself out of a thought
monoculture and get out into a more
accepting potentially or find other
people that believe in what you believe
now why do you choose a theism though I
think there's pretty much
the religious fielded needs the least
evidence yes it's not really a religious
view a better way to describe my views
that I think I have my facebook instead
I believe Dutch simplistic almost first
in the universe and later complexity so
like secondly I believe that like you're
sufficiently advanced AI would pretty
much be able to act in a certain way
that people that people would call it
God but something like that comes later
in the universe and evolves out of
simpler things so the universe started
out with the Big Bang and in the origin
during they're only like three types of
three types of elements like hydrogen
lithium and Halim I think there were
only three elements and later stars are
formed and from the new elements and
later and later the earth was formed
yeah so complexity something that comes
later in the universe from simplicity I
think we are rather than a very complex
agent like a God
creating simpler things
so I think that that's the print that's
pretty much the way in which I would
summarize my religious views but you
can't you could have you could
technically have things are actually
magic or yeah
godlike but they vote from simple things
you know the there's something about
just the labels that are strange of like
atheist or or religious or agnostic or
whatever it's just they're all just very
strange like label aside I our
perception in this three-dimensional
reality is just so limited that it's
just funny that we then try and you know
I guess a ranger or label things but I
do enjoy the idea of like all that is or
or some sort of yeah
okay what about hedonism this ties with
utilitarianism yeah hey Denise thank you
to the tourism is pretty much classical
to Lutheranism I think like the first
authors that did the first authors that
started out utilitarianism they were
hidden utilitarians the counterpart for
that is preferences in tourism which
came later and it measures more I think
it became more popular because it merges
something that is easier to measure the
world urges people's preferences and in
economic statutes like simply measured
by how much people pay for certain
things and I think that preference the
Chile terrorism is more complex more
complicated and depends on more
assumptions than hidden needs to get to
the tyranny as I'm even though it seems
simpler because you can measure how much
people want to pay for scent of things
and drink to preferences because it's
easier to translate he donated to the
tourism to like other beings such as
animals and possibly like machines in
the future who could have feelings it's
easier to apply a hidden easy to
terrorism cross a wider range of
DIF different degrees of consciousness
and different degrees of intelligence
than it is for preface utilitarianism I
think I don't know how common hidden
exciting terrorism is as opposed to
preferences in terrorism among my
friends and among they a community but
it seems to be almost evenly lay the
most I think and hidden a secret cell
Tarun ism is what I side with and how
does that relate to your initial period
of like feeling maybe a little bit
depressed or or anxious um
back then
yeah when I had like most of when I had
my mental health issues I I was a little
turn yet I wasn't mutate area at a time
um I think I was mostly libertarian
because it says to get oversized with a
libertarianism when you are a 16 year
old depressed kid but later I think it
was a friend of my um from Czech
Republic
I call him a mule and his name is
anybody um he's my best friend
I think I would say he's my best friend
and he was pretty much a person who made
to me here in utilitarian that was after
I that was pretty much after I had
gotten better from my defensive episode
so it was later did you feel any like
hedonism or what were the things that
you were feeling during that time for
you
I don't think I was very concerned with
that
like back in the time when I was really
struggling I it was difficult to like it
was difficult for me to care a lot about
happy ISM care a lot about heavy fell
because I was hopeless most of the time
when I was actually struggling so that
said I became like concerned like
hopeful about making everyone be happy
pretty much after I recovered this is a
reoccurring theme for people that I know
is that they they like see the world and
then they realize that there's a lot of
work to be done and then they go through
this period of like oh my gosh and then
I think that's when some of the link
depression their anxiety or some of the
you realize that your only option is to
take the burden off your back of
building the solutions yeah is that what
it was yeah right now this I feel yeah
thirty like it yeah you got a fall in
love with the journey yes yeah
otherwise it's yeah it's miserable along
the way yeah like something that makes
software so cool is that it allows you
to do so many things I in the past
people simply couldn't do all that
people needed to team up to do in
nowadays there is a lot of stuff that's
one person one passionate person can do
by themselves using software using
programming and machine learning
and I plan to be this person that's
badass I love it thanks from you get a
high five for that that was really good
I like that that was really good
because you're right there's we had this
example I like using Satoshi Nakamoto as
an example although he has a team or she
or whatever this individual or this
group or entity whatever it is is I
think it's very interesting to think of
people being able to go and into like
anonymous and like oh exiled like
settings away from civilization for long
periods of time and be able to build
really powerful tools like strokes of
genius can happen and then they can come
back if they want anonymously if they
want with their own personal information
and deliver that message or tool to the
world to you know to put it into big use
so I like I like thinking about using
computer science machine learning you're
right that you can make a massive impact
at scale with software that's very
interesting whereas like with a physical
thing it's much more difficult with a
digital thing like software it's much
easier to scale something like a smart
mood can get out to a billion people
through a download on an internet store
but making a cup and giving getting that
cup to a billion people is a disaster in
comparison yeah okay so I wanna I wanna
you know I want to play on this point a
little bit more because I think not too
many people like fully realize that that
this is kind of what an an entrepreneur
or an artist or a a person that's trying
to solve some sort of a problem or make
some sort of a process better in the
world is usually not necessarily like
the happiest person at times because
like we were talking about there is a
burden that's coming on to the back we
kind of see that a little bit with like
you know some of the larger like tech
CEOs we kind of see that a little bit we
also see that a little bit with even
people that are just working at the
organizations that are building those
products that it's just a lot of work
it's a lot of daily grind and hustle in
order to build software or cars or
rockets or biotech companies or anything
mapping the brain or whatever people are
doing nowadays
so do you so where do you see the future
of being able to map the current states
of people's and moods with their burden
that they're taking on their backs of
building out really important projects
in the world I hope people use it to
optimize the process and to make it as
pleasant and as effective as possible
like whatever it is that they're trying
to be it in their lives I hope that they
can make it be as pleasant to the
journey as possible so so agree with you
the tools for making the journey more
effective and more in love with the
journey is so so crucial this is one of
them there's so many others that I think
are are coming very important tool set
ok how about we ask you a couple of the
questions that we like asking on the way
out do you feel like we covered a good
amount about journey yeah yeah ok cool
just want to make sure if there's
anything else let me know
do you think we're alone in the cosmos
it depends in this universe I think it's
possible um but like there probably are
other universes with on other
civilizations but to think it's possible
that there can be other Indian
civilizations the problem is that we
haven't had a lot of evidence like
there's the Fermi paradox and everything
and I read the most recent paper right
about it was something from last year
from understand Berg and a few waters
that I remember who exactly but they
examined trig equation the equation that
calculates the probability of there
being other civilization in the universe
and they seem to have pretty much solved
the Fermi paradox but you've seen by
using intervals of intervals in the
Drake Equation of the Asthma tubes
instead of using um like the average of
a certain estimate which means that it
actually they pretty much figure out
that it actually isn't very unlikely
that we are alone in this universe at
least so that was the most recent paper
that I have read about this issue but I
believe that it's not unlikely at all
that there are other universes out there
and other civilizations I think that's
very likely connection
of course can I say something regarding
there's no evidence of alien existence I
want everybody to hear me out
yes right look at the planet with all
the plants and the animals as one and
then look at this human experiment and
then reconsider the fact that there is
no evidence of alien life on this planet
that's all it's interesting point what
do you what do you feel about the human
experiment just being like an anomaly
compared to all the other life oh I
think it's it's a very complicated
question because
of the anthropic bias so there's this
interesting thing where the things that
we are most likely to observe and like
just there is of the universe and
aspects of the universe that are most
likely to be observed at all to have an
observer they are the areas with the
least entropy with the most negentropy
that's a word that I use sometimes and
but that doesn't mean that the most
observed areas are the ones with the
least least entropy yeah
like here like here yeah okay so these
are nice and this is organized the human
experiment is organized compared to the
rest of the world like in terms of
entropy like there is less entropy in
Earth's Indian biological organisms and
yeah like there's of the universe that
allowed life they have less entropy than
the rest of the universe because the
configurations of items that allow that
allow observer six days that allow us to
exist they are very narrow and they're
very specific so like if you deviate too
much from you forget any anymore any
human being and you make them you know
make their configuration very different
from what it is they can very easily
cease function like you feel stop eating
for a few days you know you won't you
won't function as as good as you as
usual function if you stop drinking you
want function so like there's a very
narrow range of states in which
conscious experience can happen
and we are we find ourselves in those
very narrow in the inlet very narrow
range because we are observers so but
that doesn't mean that it's something
that is bound to become or or something
that it's meant to be or is it something
like very special because like in a
certain way when it comes to entropy we
are most likely to observe the areas in
the universe they're very much the least
likely which is like the areas are on us
whereas most of the universe is just
nothing it's not very interesting
yeah 96 or some percent is just not
planets and stars yeah just have like
dark energy and dark matter and empty
space and yeah yeah
interesting yeah I have to understand
that that was anthropic bias towards
where our perception is allocated and
its relation to entropy and need to
understand that more okay this is
simulation so we must ask you are we in
a simulation I think it's very possible
yeah I think it's actually it's a very
cute hypothesis I haven't given much
thought about it but I think it's pretty
much likely yeah but we are I don't
think it's a crazy theory I think it's
most likely to be um just the way things
are and only thing is that the way
things are for most observers indeed in
all of the universe's maybe maybe most
of the observers are in a simulation
maybe that's I think that's likely to be
the case that's what's up
I love that I love that most of the
observers are in simulations
maybe yeah yeah maybe you know it
definitely feels like that sometimes
yeah and it feels like we're gonna just
end up making another layer eventually
within this century we're just gonna
make our own simulations and
yeah it's always funny to think about
fast-forwarding 13.8 billion years in
the simulation and just being like look
it's us yeah okay and the last question
that we like asking what's the most
beautiful thing in the world
the journey of
making the world a better place and
feeling great while you're doing it it's
like feeling meaning meaning that you
experience meaning in life by oh you
improve the lives of others I think
that's what I would say
that's a really good yeah having a
really good journey of making the world
a better place and just being in love
with it and being in love with existence
is really really powerful they tell you
this has been such a pleasure thank you
for coming on to the show thank you for
meeting me here we really appreciate it
thank you thank you keep up the good
work we're all counting on you thank you
thank you everyone you can find the
links below to Natalya's work smart mood
that io is walls for a website go and
check it out
give her a follow on twitter for check
her work out on facebook as well go and
check that out and thank you to Ron
Vargas a producer and director we
greatly appreciate you thank you thank
you thank you and give us your thoughts
in the comments below on what we talked
about this is a very interesting episode
covering a wide range of topics on both
like philosophies as well as on mental
health and well-being productivity
happiness so give us your thoughts below
join the public telegram and WeChat
there a lot also everyone support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in support them our links are
below if you find this content useful
join us help us scale help us build and
build your dreams into the world
everyone manifest your destiny go and
execute go and create we love you so
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]